all right so we've got a few people that
already commenting what questions and
all right here we go
all right hot breath averse welcome back
to the hot breath podcast this is the
show where you learn comedy from the
pros and this is a very special episode
we're in a very special time so I
reached out to a very special person to
hopefully help us all to maximize the
most out of our time with what is
currently happening first off I hope
everyone is staying safe out there
staying smart out there we're seeing a
lot of different comedians trying a lot
of different things on social media
specifically right now since no one has
shows no one has any bookings we're all
just trying to figure out this internet
thing and how we can use it to stay in
contact with our fan base or to even
just help continue to build a fan base
so we know social media is a very
powerful tool to do all that so we're
connecting with a fellow hop brethren
this guy is actually a loyal listener
for a long time now I caught his radar
on social media when he was selling
merch like crazy and we actually
scheduled a phone call together to
discuss how he's able to do that and he
gave me some tips on mine and now he is
here to give us some tips on how we can
all maximize the opportunity we're
sitting in front of cuz you know let's
look at this glass half-full
and it'll be a good challenge for all of
us I think to start using social media
more as a tool instead of as a toy for
distraction so please this is actually a
live Q&A we're gonna be doing here in
the hot breath comedy Network Facebook
group so if you're not a member of that
join in on that it'll be linked in the
show notes as well but hop in that group
there's listeners from around the world
and we're starting to do a lot more
interactive content in there so with all
that being said ladies and gentlemen hop
brother and sister and welcome to the
hot breath averse the one and only Zach
Lyman
everyone give it up for Zack Lyman
everyone make some noise all together
and and having this opportunity right
now because yeah I I'm excited too
anytime we get a talk marketing and any
time we're gonna talk with comedians
about marketing so perfect well just to
start it off maybe give people just a
little background on you who you are
where you're coming from and even like
what you're hoping to kind of accomplish
with this as well yeah yeah one of the
reasons I constantly listen to your
podcast Joel is because you and I are
almost similar amount of time in comedy
I've been doing it for 11 years 11 years
of comedy mostly started in Phoenix
moved around a little bit but my first
job ever like for a long period of time
was a barista in coffee making coffee a
small coffee shop and I say that because
I kept coming back to being a barista
and doing comedy and and then a few
years ago I was doing marketing for a
different kind of company a baby product
and we had some viral videos take off
and then a coffee company kind of
scouted me out and I started working
with them and a bunch of their clients
and kind of just being able to use my
time as a barista and my marketing
knowledge together and then over that
time I started really picking up steam
and I was able to apply the things that
I learned for comedy and marketing to
them to those businesses mm-hmm and in
the first year of like working for this
large company I made them like millions
of dollars off of Instagram and Facebook
and
and I was able to kind of like hone in
skills
so I could like run ads with them and
then I could kind of take that knowledge
and be like but how can I apply that to
comedy and that's all I would be doing
is constantly using my day job in
marketing to then go home and be like
okay but what if I did this in comedy
mm-hmm and so just applying that and so
yeah 11 years in comedy and countless
years of marketing within that time on
and off and now I'm full-time comedian
and just really like like you said like
last year I kind of like did the super
dive in of just trying to live off of
merch and so I had a shirt that kind of
blew up and lived off of that for a
while
and now I'm just kind of like shirts
podcast and live shows mixture and just
trying to keep the the plates spinning
because we're talking earlier yeah and
what did what major shirt blow up so
much was there some specific you did
that kind of sparked it or was a gradual
over time trial and error it was
probably because I've done most of my
shirt designs myself and so I've done
all these different designs and I was
never really a fan of like anything that
fell like inside baseball where it's
like you'd have to know my joke
to get the t-shirt and then I also like
anytime I know same time it had my name
on it
maybe it was just the design but maybe
it was just having my name on it people
didn't want to wear my name and so I
just started thinking about designs that
were in essence of me and my comedy and
also that like looked good to wear and
then I came up with the shirt comedy and
naps that's perfect that's like exactly
me
I love naps and I love comedy that's a
simple text and I liked how it looked
and the spacing on the shirt
and so I put that up and I sold a few
and built a little traction and then I
started having like Instagram
influencers where them
okay influencer marketing that's what
yeah so that's what ended up happening
is like a few of them that I knew
personally bought the shirt and then
helped promote me and then I gave like
maybe four away to other influencers
because I saw how well that happened
with my friends and then at one point
Nathalie Friedman who's a influencer and
impressionist and she does stand-up also
she's so many things she's very talented
she's like a million followers on
Instagram and she posted my shirt and
just that day alone was like what a
great day the influencer marketing is
what really took the shirt off was just
like different influencers and different
people with any following really micro
influencers mm-hmm so anytime someone
big wore it like maybe five different
smaller accounts would buy it and wear
it and so and they within those
followers and kind of like trickle down
right right because people are like you
know they're watching what the big
influencers are doing and then they're
trying to do that to grow their own
influencer following so they're working
with us a guy's a climbin I'll just buy
his shirt and wear and promote it and
I'll fit in with those hashtags and
everything yeah yeah yeah it just kind
of like snowballs into taking off for
quite a while and now I'm like
introducing like new shirt designs and
what I would love to do is I'd love to
just keep making new shirts all the time
mm-hmm and just have constantly be
running new and just kind of throwing
ideas out cuz it cost me like nothing to
get one shirt printed you know so might
as well get one shirt printed I model it
or someone else and
and try it out for a bit yeah and it
that is important to kind of focusing on
what is working and then kind of
doubling down on that and with specially
with social media it's like there are
certain strategies and tips that like
specific things you can do to maximize
your growth and reach on social media
and really this kind of leads in please
people watching comment with your
questions the first one here actually
comes from EJ masa Campo who actually I
did I did a show in North Carolina last
year and he actually let me stay at his
place with his children he trusted me
and it all went great and look at where
we are now very it was very much so
trusting and even my wife was like
really
is he gonna actually she didn't actually
know till after cuz she probably have
been like really you're gonna go stay
with but it's the hot breath averse you
know if you know you know and the people
listening and watching this know so
comment with your questions everyone EJ
asked he has some background from Zak
which is what we just got that but
really we talked about your merch but I
think this is interesting he asked and
how he uses social media so you as a
comedian coming from you know this
coffee space where you've actually
spoken at festivals about marketing as
well so it how do you as a comedian
apply what you've learned from working
with that coffee company how do you
apply it to your own comedy that other
comedians could do okay like like a
program like sprout social there's like
a really good one I love that program
but it's like a hundred dollars a month
and you know so it's kind of like one of
those things away comics can't use that
but I quickly was learning what they
were doing with that program and how
they were doing it and it was like like
social tracks like all the hashtags and
they're like watching what hashtags get
you more
views I was like okay you can kind of
like shoot-from-the-hip and do that
of play with different hashtags of like
small hashtags medium sized hashtags
large hashtags and what I mean by that
is small hashtags maybe like there's
only a thousand posts in that hashtag
and then like a medium hashtag has like
30,000 posts and then a large hashtag
has a million posts mom and so if you're
a small or Instagram you're like going
to be mixing that together right you're
gonna be like try like if you only have
500 followers you might get on the top
of the small hashtag and get some
traction in that hashtag but maybe that
will push you just enough to get bigger
in the medium sized hashtag and then if
you're super lucky that will give you
enough traction to get higher up ranking
in the large hashtag and then that's
like how things go viral on Instagram
climbing those hashtags in the right
order and mixing around with small
medium and large hashtags and then being
able to get into the top of those you
know top view and now we have like the
discovery page which is like a whole
nother conversation but like I learned
how to like kind of like perfect that
from working with them and constantly
posting on their instagrams and what
they're changing and then also I just
saw what it was like to have like a
marketing budget of any sort you know
versus like US comics for like I have
$10 that I could spend on that so it's
kind of like really learning like like
deep analytics is something that I
learned from marketing jobs that I
applied a comedy it's just like running
maybe five different ads at once and
then knowing that you're gonna cancel
four of them right so I've run five ads
cancel four of um
keep the one that's really crushing it
and keep playing with that so that way
I do have only 40 dollars I can spend
I'm gonna end up spending it on the
right ad and so just throwing it all
away on one ad that doesn't work so if
you're posting like let's just say I got
a joke about you timeout coronavirus or
something which you would then hashtag
it like you would search hashtags around
the phrase coronavirus and around the
phrase joke and around the phrase stand
up and stuff like that what is the small
medium largest of coronavirus the
different ways it's also like covet 19
okay what is you know and then I'm a big
fan of like tagging where you're from or
maybe where the joke is from like
Phoenix Tempe bringing down cities doing
in the mixing that in there and then
yeah and then like stand-up but then
also just like writing jokes right like
you don't want to go with the first idea
you come with you want to come up with
like the third punchline right right
so the same with like marketing so it's
like everyone's reaching for stand-up
what's another way I can say stand-up
that's not stand up okay hashtag the
Comedy Cellar
okay that's very you know leaning
towards like people that are looking up
the Comedy Cellar gonna see it but it's
still stand up
okay what about Comedy Central specials
can I throw that in there and then
people that are looking up Comedy
Central specials they're gonna come and
like just really take an extra second to
think about and then come up with like
your core 10 that you're kind of always
playing with or changing and then adding
from there you know so yeah it's like
and then also
hash tag videos comedy videos you know
I'm kind of play with that and see you
recommend like doing around ten you said
you don't want to be belligerent I mean
some people their entire post is
hashtags that they were saying that this
year
Instagram was very lenient on the idea
of what because you can do I think up to
30 if you wanted but they're kind of
like paying attention to people that
only do like 10 to 15 and they're like
purposely kind of leaning it a certain
way
yeah I do think that's probably true
like 10 is probably you've probably
covered it okay
and so hashtags is one way we can use
social media what are some others yeah
like I did because it's like Joel you
know this consistency is key yep that's
like yep for everything yep
so one thing that I did was I created
this thing called ten-second jokes and
then I create my own hashtag for
ten-second jokes and then it was like
sure I can categorize all my jokes into
one right so I can just kind of go back
and look and see how many have done and
what I was doing when I started it was
it was kind of like a very much a time
like this in my life when I started
doing it was I had no job because I just
moved across the country and I had no
friends nothing going on and I was like
well I can write a 10 second joke a day
mm-hmm which is very much just a setup
in a punchline and and I can post that
every day so what I was doing was
consistently posting one joke and I
would have tagged the different topics
and then some of them got like no views
some of them got a lot of views some of
them got a lot of shares some of them
got no you know it was just very up and
down yeah but the one thing that I got
out of it was followers was I constantly
was getting followers from constantly
posting and it was like you know we're
doing seven jokes a week like that's so
many different avenues for people to
come in and find you so consistently
come up with a job make yourself a job
and make yourself every day make that
thing you know like right now I was
telling you earlier that like I'm doing
30 minute marketing videos on my own
personal Facebook every day that's my
job right now nice it's see it's like
when I wake up in
morning I get I put on the cleanest
shirt I own and I go alright let's talk
about marketing for 30 minutes and and
that's just like and now people are
sharing that and that's getting
different things but for the most part
it's just consistency you know yeah
consume consistently posting and are you
planning these posts like if you're
doing seven jokes in a week are you like
planning them out day by day or you just
kind of waking up and winging it geez
talk about consistency yeah like I took
breaks when I came back from it you know
but for the most part I would anytime I
like committed to doing it I would do it
for a week couple weeks you know a
couple days something right and it was
like still always building so sometimes
yeah sometimes I was completely like oh
here's the next five days for sure I
have all these joke ideas sometimes I
was like stressing all day that was like
I haven't thought of a single joke but
it definitely made me write more
material than I've ever written which
then translate some of those ten-second
jokes actually became full jokes and my
stand-up but um yeah like it made me
write more and then I was just kind of
planning and then when I realized I was
20 away from a hundred I did 20 and 20
days god she's like my goal for like
that month and and that was traveling
for shows and stuff like that and so
there was times where I was like on the
plane being like I'm not gonna get home
until 11 p.m. and I'm barely gonna make
the deadline of posting it at like 11:30
p.m. and I kind of enjoyed that never
knowing what time it's gonna go up never
knowing there's kind of like my own
thrill because I've done 80 like it was
a nice way to mix it up in like kind of
pressure myself so yeah so posting
consistently posting jokes hashtags is
another one are there any other ways off
the
of your head that comedians and these
are and we're thinking about like when
we say comedians we're not thinking of
like Joe Rogan or Bert Kreischer you
know we're thinking of comedians like
you and I
comedians maybe only a year or two in as
well who everyone's kind of everyone's
like well what now
you know like are there any other things
that come to mind for comedians more
like us and younger that they can be
using social media to build a following
but also just to like use it more
productively than just scrolling you
know I think yesterday about leaning
into your passion okay so that's like a
big one for me is like we've already
brought up how I enjoy coffee and I
really do and I'm constantly posting on
my Instagram story and I'm constantly I
go to coffee fest and then I started
speaking at coffee with us now I do
stand-up at coffee fests and so it's
very much me or the last couple years of
leaning into it that's what I like and
I'm meeting like-minded people that do
those things and I think that's that's
important right so it's important to
find what you're passionate about and
then join those Facebook groups and then
network with those people in those
groups and then find like just right now
is the perfect time to just be
constantly meeting new people online
that are into like if you're into Honda
scooters going into a Honda scooter
groups and talking to them about Honda
scooters at some point comedy will come
up and they'll come to your show or want
your podcast or whatever and that's a
great way to be using marketing every
day every day hands looking into
hashtags for what you enjoy looking into
Facebook groups perfect you can do that
stuff an another way that I think that
comics need to think about when they're
posting is what's shareable is it normal
what you're making
like this I leaned away from anything
that's way too inside baseball well it's
like only my friends and the Phoenix
comedy scene are gonna understand this
joke or understand this thing I leaned
away from that I I really leaned into
what's shareable which came back to my
shirt comedy naps mm-hmm you don't have
to Know Who I am at all to enjoy that
shirt you know you have to know that I'm
a comedian and you don't have to know
that that's my merch but it's very
shareable because it's a good shirt so
just keep that in mind when you're
creating a joke creating a podcast
creating a video of any sort
what is shareable and uh sorry this is a
personal thing can you turn your camera
a little bit we're cutting off about a
quarter of your face and there we go
okay
sorry that was so funny yeah because I
could like it was almost cutting off
your right eye and I was like oh let's
let's let's get that framed up here on
skype for people on YouTube and a
Facebook so I'm sure someone else out
there was like dude great info but
please I want to see all of Zach's
beautiful face and I eat
EJ's already saying this has been crazy
helpful and ramier also said super
helpful I like the Facebook groups ideas
and it's true like I think it definitely
has comedians we can get caught up in
just the comedy world and it's like what
within my world can I start to like
build an interest and following it but
it really is like no what is your
interest go into that world and build
your following that way it's authentic
yeah I'm like this is really what I care
about
I'm not secretly in the back of my brain
being like when do I get it bring up my
podcast
I'm just enjoying the conversation and
then they add me on Facebook at some
point or they follow me on Instagram and
they're like oh I didn't know he made
all these videos let me check that out I
love it oh I love that one so let's um
let's let's follow that momentum into
Lynch's question he asked what's most
important to get more people to follow
you content quality are putting stuff
out there more consistently
let's take Instagram for example right
now if you're trying to get followers on
Instagram I look at the main page it's
changed over the years but now I look at
the main page of your your poet your
actual post is like super quality that's
like prime like like I went through and
I posted all the I did a photo shoot and
I posted all those photo shoot
you know like nice super high quality
photos great but your Instagram story is
the behind the scenes it's that your
day-to-day it's your here's me making a
cup of coffee here's me hanging out and
you're tagging cuz you can do hashtags
and Instagram stories you can do geo
tagging you can tag the company that
you're drinking a coffee from and so
you're getting followers from the
stories but also you're just doing prime
quality on your main page so I would say
quality way over
how often so if you're just posting once
a week on your actual page but you're
constantly posting your Instagram story
you're probably doing pretty well
oh okay that's good to know and see most
poor day how it's important yeah we all
want followers as well I mean I guess
that kind of ties into how we do it is
through going to places you're already
naturally interested in and I guess even
like we're talking about posting daily
content you want to make sure it's
something you're interested in so you
can actually do it at a sustainable rate
as well you have any more any tips on
the actual process of getting followers
those vanity numbers we all love even
though I can attest from interviewing a
lot of other social media people is like
the vanity number
it may feel good to you but that metric
is really outdated in terms of the
actual impact you can have and it's
really more about engagement so if
you're posting something you genuinely
care about and you're posting it for an
audience that you're a genuine member of
that's where you're really going to get
that engagement and start to build those
quality followers and have an actual
following as opposed to just follow
words yeah
it touches base on like when I go to
coffee fest and I speak they're not
marketing on the screen is my Instagram
that's the only thing I promote it's
mine like I picked one platform that I'm
gonna just promote right so I'm always
promoting my Instagram everywhere and I
get true followers out of that so I may
speak to 300 people and a hundred of
them follow me right
that's great numbers and those are
really active followers right it goes
back to engagement and stuff like that
but if you're just trying to get your
numbers up like I've worked for
businesses and they just have goals in
mind where they're like we want 50,000
followers just because we are a big
company and we should look like a big
company Instagram ads you to Facebook
Ads any of that stuff if you're trying
to just get the numbers run ads gotcha
and the power of a ten dollar ad is
insane right now especially right now
everyone's at home right yeah so like
right now I'm running in an Instagram
and Facebook ad and I've spent $6 and I
think when I checked it this morning I
was like something over like 8,000
people have looked at it and it's cost
me a fraction of a penny for every
person that's clicked on my page and so
how will you run that ad can you break
down even the process of someone wanting
to run an ad like we see the option on
social media but how
what's the most effective way to run an
ad doing it on Facebook and then having
it run to Instagram if it's a picture
okay mine is a picture and then having
the so you you run the ad on Facebook
like make the post on your Facebook page
hit the boost button create an audience
and then that audience is people that
would like your stuff right so people
that listen to podcasts people that like
comedy people in this country people in
other countries and they also speak your
language you know just try and keep all
of that in mind that just doesn't need
to be your neighborhood create all that
as details you can think about your
fanbase what you know is it all male is
it all female is it a mixture of both
female and male great where are the age
ranges play that then run the ad on
Facebook and Instagram which is an
option if you have them connected
through your Facebook page and then and
then just pay attention to like what is
the traction of the ad is it getting a
lot of views is getting a lot of likes
is it getting a lot of what you want for
your money if it's costing you $5.00 a
day and you're getting no likes on it
it's a bad Act just cancel just don't
don't be so invested into your idea
about it just create no one you know use
a different picture use a different
thing you know it goes back to I liked
running five ads canceling for gotcha
and for $10 you run five ads yeah and
I'll set them all for $10 okay so $50
total all right okay so I may only spend
30 cents a dollar of the ad before I
realize this isn't gonna work
wow I'm a I'm gonna try to get close to
as possible my ten dollars that I want
to spend I may end up spending 11 or
whatever but you know I'm gonna try to
get to close to 10
and I'm just gonna try to always keep
that money on that one so I tell
Facebook all of them for $10 and I'm
just completely aligning to them and
setting them on for the same amount of
days or whatever and then I'm just gonna
cancel them maybe it right in the
morning maybe a couple hours a couple
hours you know yeah I'm just gonna be
checking in on every day every morning
every so often depends on you know how
much do you need that $10 so if you're
okay with throwing like way couple bucks
sure but if you're not okay we're
throwing away a couple boats I'm
checking them every a couple hours or so
and being like okay this is there's no
uptick here yeah what are you looking
for when you say you're checking them
specifically my is a penny per click
okay so if I get a penny per click on
like on an ad that's a penny going to
like the Buy Now button that's a penny
for getting a like that's a penny for it
you know what I mean so whatever my goal
that I told Facebook is going to be like
I told Facebook that I'm trying to get
wet traction and so I put in a link and
I had them go to a direct link or
whatever um I'm looking for a
pay-per-click I'm looking for a lot of
engagement you know like the atom ring
right now when I saw right away there
was like like right away a couple
thousand people saw it and I was like oh
this is going somewhere you know and it
cost me like 30 cents to reach a
thousand people 30 cents yeah why do you
think you got that pop on that specific
post I think it's a good picture I think
good picture okay yeah I think it's
colorful I think okay I always think
about you have three seconds when people
are scrolling you know you have three
second second max so when I'm posting an
atom like in 3 seconds do you get what
I'm selling do you get any of this you
know and so that's what I I think I
picked the right picture for that yeah
so paper
like lots of engagement and just go with
your gut you know and just be I know I
don't feel like this is the one cancel
it and then just keep making new ones
until you've spent your money and then
you're like alright I least got
something out of it or maybe I learned a
lot about myself for 10 bucks yeah and
it is yeah a lot of trial and error just
like our material I guess it is some
point just a lot of trial and error nice
and this this kind of piggybacks on so
this next question is kind of jumping
the line but it does piggyback on our
hashtag topic real quick
Mookie asks do you have hash tags to the
nice photos on your IG main page hash
tag every photo okay everything
everything and I'm a big fan of leaving
like posting the posting it and then
right away leaving the hash tags as a
comment leaving the hash tag okay so
post the caption and then leave a hash
tag as the comment yeah because I
already told Facebook that I have a
comment
I told Instagram that I have a comment
and then I'm getting all the hash tags
so it's like I'm getting the engagement
up already and I'm you know adding all
the roads to get to that picture perfect
alright moving on this is so cool by the
way dude people are already saying like
this is this has been super helpful to
them so the people oh dude Thank You Man
this is a this is great and for the
people watching I have been periodically
posting putting up his Instagram handle
for for you to go check out if you want
to see actually how he's using it if you
can't see it and you're just listening
I'm sorry join the Facebook group and
then you can see it but it is at Zach
Lymon podcast za c k ly ma n podcast if
while you're listening to this you'd
like to scroll through and see his
social media feed moving on and remember
kids keep posting your questions
whatever social media questions
you have we want to get them answered
today and really start you know this
whole shows about helping comics and now
more than ever it seems like everyone's
almost trying to figure it out it's the
Wild West again in terms of what's gonna
work what's not how am I gonna maximize
my time and what do I do
even you know what do I do with all this
time so yeah it's important this is an
important discussion so Karly sherek
asked when to put up on the screen
this is dude these these little features
man I mean this is this is our first
time using this but these beats I mean
then the names coming up the names are
coming up we have title cards and this
is this is gonna be something kids so so
carly asks so it's today and you want to
build up a following from scratch what
are the first three things you would do
oh great question okay I would first
establish how much money I can spend $50
of $5 is it and then that would lead me
into what do I like what what apps do I
already like right I am a big fan of
Instagram already okay I love I'm on
Instagram anyways so I would be like
okay I'm gonna pick Instagram I have $10
to spend great and then I would decide
what am i posting am i posting am i
gonna post videos pictures do I have a
show idea that I could do on Instagram
in 30 seconds or whatever okay and then
I so I would figure out Instagram I'm
gonna make weekly videos and I'm gonna
spend ten dollars a month and these
videos are gonna be this type of comedy
so I'm gonna follow I'm gonna follow a
bunch of counts that I like hmm I'm
gonna follow a bunch of counselor may be
doing the same thing to give me
inspiring sergeant
Paige I'm forced to look at people doing
what I want to do and then what else
would I do
I would probably then just start looking
deep into hashtags okay I I'm a huge fan
of like like for me like I am I already
know marketing but I am constantly
watching webinars YouTube anytime like
even when I worked at a company and I
would get phone calls where marketing
companies would call me and say that
they can do their mark my marketing
better right I would sit in on their
hour call of them telling me what
they're gonna do and so I'm always like
yeah teach me teach me what we're gonna
do and now I can apply that and so
whatever video I want to do like if I
already know how to write sketch comedy
I'm still gonna go to youtube and type
in how to write sketch comedy
I'm just watching what people are making
how they're doing different things and
so I would be constantly learning about
the thing that I want to post on
Instagram and then I would be telling
everyone about it I think that's a very
important key is telling all your
friends that you're doing it and that
reminding them they're like I'm doing it
tomorrow I'm making it tomorrow
I made it today yesterday I made it and
constantly be reminding people that
that's what you do that's your thing and
I would just like out deep dive into
especially right now with all this free
time right I'll be making like if I
wanted to make 10 second jokes again
right now I'll be making five ten
seconds oakes a day if possible 10 SEC's
you know I make like crazy lists for
myself to-do lists and just be knocking
that out and I'll be creating all kinds
of content and then it goes back to just
like joke writing ways like you write 10
jokes and then you go and you're like
I'm really only gonna use this one right
and so I would be creating a bunch of
content for Instagram and then being
like no only these five I'll post and
then you're just setting a different bar
with your quality that's what I have the
question yeah yeah these are great you
actually gave us more than three but I
mean these are all great tips and
is i have heard like batch recording as
I'm I'm going deep onto YouTube now when
you're talking about one of your great
tips was like think about where you want
to post cuz it's like you can post on
every platform like averagely or you can
pick one that you're really passionate
that's really intuitive to you and just
produce quality content on there so yeah
that's that that's super valuable and
I'm thinking in terms of this made me
selfishly think because she was like you
the question was if you're building a
following from scratch so what about if
let's say you're me for instance it's if
hypothetically there was a comedian with
a podcast than a comedy special and you
know just hypothetically what would you
tell them you know I love yeah I do do
that but I mean hey take strike while
the iron's hot you know why you got the
audience so okay good guess okay so for
me for instance you knowing what you
know about me cuz you are an engaged hot
Brethren you have been in the hot breath
verse for a while now and knowing what
you know about me in terms of I have a
comedy special I released about a month
ago maybe we maybe we do that one cuz I
was trying to think of the podcast
marketing also but maybe like because
people since doing the the special you
know the goal was to inspire other
comics to create their own projects
whether it is a special or it's an album
or it's their a sketch whatever just
inspiring comics to invest in themselves
and create how would you recommend I
market this comedy special it's called
the trophy husband you know so
and if you guys are listening right now
and you haven't listened to Joel's
episode talking about making it I really
enjoyed that episode oh you guys broke
down like the the good and the bad of
making it and the things you learned
from it because it was super helpful for
me because I at some point want to
record a special that I haven't and I
probably will end up doing it
self-produced probably on YouTube or
something you know something something
that way of so I like the approach that
you took and I really like that episode
of you breaking it down oh great yeah of
course man I how many of the jokes have
you released have you released any of
the jokes so see no I I made like one I
had a joke about playing football that I
put together and then released on like
Super Bowl Sunday and then like never
again type deal you know so you think
maybe parsing up jokes like a bunch of
other comics are doing type deal yeah
you know promoting specials forever and
every time we always know that they pick
like one very mainstream joke I kind of
it's for everyone that also shows off
the comedian in a certain way and then
they just have that one joke that
they're constantly being like check out
this person this weekend at this time
you know right and it's always like just
this 10 second or maybe a minute long or
you know and then like even you know
move please have trailers separately
that like maybe think of releasing a
couple quick jokes from the specials
like little snippets that you can kind
of post and maybe it's not even a full
joke maybe it's like you in the middle
of a joke and you're saying something
that's already ridiculous or funny by
itself and then just kind of like
cutting straight to like a head of like
on you know because it's on patreon
right no it's actually it's on my
website but it is okay it's
yeah it is like a pay what you can so
there's no like set price but it is yeah
it is on my website Joel buyers comedy
calm okay so then it would be a quick
snippet that says go to Joe Weider's a
calm and like even you could be running
the ad and you could be doing like a
10-second ad and have a button that's
like Buy It Now and it just goes
directly to the buy page of that okay so
I would be thinking about that I was
thinking about doing some some
screenshots in general just some
pictures of it that are really good and
just promoting it that way okay and then
maybe you could do you could go onto
other people's podcasts and talk about
how you self produced an album or
a special and talk about how you did it
on other people's podcasts and then
maybe every so often releasing like like
every month or whatever releasing like a
new part of it or just releasing a video
of you talking about it being like I
just thought about I changed this one
joke or like I redid this joke that's
actually on the special or you know
kinda like revisiting it right right
right yeah I would just be that's how I
would be doing and then also I would
just be I'll be running I'd be running
like 20 different ads that are all
different like a screenshot a snippet
video a different kind of stupid video
different overlays and I'll just be
doing that at once and seeing where
people are enjoying and not enjoying
okay interesting sounds like I just need
to hire Zach too cuz that is the thing I
mean that's that's the thing I that's
the one thing I overlooked in this whole
process was kind of like in that episode
you listen to the referred to is when I
was with my director and we were talking
about the whole process I thought
through everything but the marketing
part of it so now I'm at like the other
end of it we're now it's out
we had a good presale and now sales
after like the first month you know of
that instant like interest it started to
taper off and now the good thing about
having your own special is its evergreen
that'll be there forever so in five
years that's gonna be just passive
income still you know but for the time
being my whole goal really with it was
to just break even on the project that's
all I really want to do is to pay for a
special that I could break even on that
would inspire other comics to you know
take action so yeah the marketing was
the one thing I didn't I put in all the
work leading up to it and then the
marketing I was like oh yeah people that
don't know me would like to see it
perhaps you know so that's good have you
seen it have you seen the special by
chance you haven't seen the special okay
so yeah maybe we'll yeah maybe we'll
talk well maybe we'll talk right now or
we'll talk off air about no no no I'm
just saying for you to see it so then
maybe that'll spark some ideas on how it
can be marketed and this could be
interesting this could be interesting
case study as well for the listeners to
almost like follow and we could almost
like Chronicle kind of like how I've
done with a Sam Gordon I don't know if
you've heard those episodes but she's uh
she's like a DIY comic has her own show
production company where she proves a
bunch of shows and she's just thought
she's the soul of hot breath like she's
the comic like the like just the the
blueprint of what we want here at hot
breath which was a comic taking their
career into their own hands and creating
their own success so we did an interview
at the middle of last year and she was
on the cusp of like thing about going
full-time or what to do and her next
step so then we did a six-month
follow-up so this could be an
interesting thing for us to maybe where
we know where we are now and maybe start
to put together like a marketing
strategy and start to look at results
and really show
the hot breath averse kind of how the
sausage is made behind and maybe give
them a blueprint kind of like I did with
my director where we wanted to give the
listeners a blueprint for how here's the
equipment we used here's how we rented
it you know here's how we pick the venue
here's how we approach the venue like
just giving all just like the granular
details of producing the special maybe
we can do it to where we give the
granular examples of now how to actually
market the special and what the
expectation would that should be I love
doing speak yeah I literally show like
slideshow of like an ad from beginning
to end and what I liked and didn't like
and how it worked because I think that's
exactly like that's how my brain works
and that's how I need to and take things
then I need to watch Joel I need to
listen to Joel talk about how he made
his special so then when I make a
special I can go Joel did this let me
think about doing that way or maybe
avoid it because he learned from that
you know and yeah I totally love to do
that with your special because you're
having one big piece of content and
you're able to make so many separate
things out of that one piece of content
right and so you can make like 80
different ads out of that one thing so
fascinating yeah I love okay great yeah
because I think it's important what I've
learned that I wish I learned early on
for younger comics listening is like you
know what are your strengths what are
your weaknesses and start to build a
team around maybe where your weaknesses
are and marketing I've never been afraid
of the work I've never been afraid of
doing things but I'm good at doing
something and then completing it and
then like that's it like I I spent hours
creating an online podcasting course
launched it and then just never said
anything about it like like it's on it's
on you to me right now but I'm gonna I
think I'm gonna move it on to a better
platform because I'm putting together
like a comedy writing online
course now so I think I'm gonna put
those all in the same place but yeah I I
do that a lot I put a lot of work into
something and then I'm like okay the
marketing people will know you know I'm
under there
we'll know you know what I mean but I
just want listeners to know all the
classes you're saying yeah yeah I agree
and I finally combined my Joel buyers
website and my hot breath website so I
those are finally combined so now it's
yeah just creating an ecosystem around
Joel buyers and hot breath which I think
the classes yeah so yeah great great
tips here please people we've got one
more we've got one more question here if
anyone else has a question comment now
or forever hold your peace so but thank
you all for hanging out and spending
time with us here on this Sunday
hopefully we'll be doing more of these
so John
Chapel or Chapel asks as a new guy on
the scene should I create separate
social media accounts for my current
personal ones or does that matter
question when you're saying new ones do
you think he's talking about he's new to
comedy yeah I'm actually I've been um we
just recently connected yeah he's a he's
very new he's very new to comedy I think
like he's done like two open mics as I'm
looking back on our messages together
yeah he's he like just did his second
open mic so yeah very new I would I
create a Facebook page for your comedy
I'll probably keep your Instagram and
your your personal page as is because
the people they're gonna come to your
shows right now are people that know you
and all your
do is cut down your fanbase so people
that are now you're you're making people
go over and click on another page and
follow that page and that's just like an
extra click that doesn't need to exist
so yeah I would just I would just keep
the pages as they are if you feel like
it represents you in your comedy maybe
take down some pictures of like you know
if you feel like they don't fit in with
what you're doing now take down those
pictures but for the most part you know
I don't see because I'm Zack Lemmon
podcast is my only Instagram and it's
very me and it's purposely carry me
gotcha and I would I would recommend
this is something that I did early on I
was sure to do is like I made everything
the same so in terms that's yeah it's I
wasn't like Joel Byers on Twitter and
then Joel Byers one two three four on
Instagram like I was sure to make all
the branding consistent so everything
you see at the podcast on social media
is at hot breath pod and everything you
see if Joel Byers is Joel Byers comedy
everything's the same so make sure it's
consistent and easy to find if you're
going by like a stage name or you're
just maybe shortened your name or
whatever for comedy just make sure
you're searchable that way so you're not
pickle juice 34 this guy everyone does
that I've never seen this guy he's
pretty funny right and then they're
searching in their phone for that person
just make sure you're easy to find or
maybe add comedy to the end of it if
there's a lot of people with your name
mm-hmm something like that
yeah yeah that's that's a that's a good
question now oh sorry I thought yeah we
lost you for a second I was like no
we're almost at the end and it just
crashes so yeah this is this is
hopefully um this is hopefully the first
of many things we do together but also
this live this live stream I'm really
enjoying I've been doing a live right 10
Club everyday at 10:00 a.m. where we all
get together
and right for ten minutes and that's
been going well I like these live
interviews so we're like oh great yeah
because I am
three hours difference right yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's a Trent Trent out on
the west coast actually he he Tunes in
at 7:00 a.m. he like gets up and he's
he's in it to win it man it's it's fun
some people say yes some comics posted
though like 10:00 a.m. what you know
you're talk about comedians right we're
not gonna give this is the military Joel
but it's like you want comedy to be your
job you've got to treat it like a job
you know and just to what what what you
get out is what you put in as well and
consistently put in we talked about
consistency today is a big part of
social media but that's a big part of
your career in general which is why I do
the right 10 Club because like I you
know I'm not immune to struggles and
failures and all that that's why I mean
I wasn't consistently writing anymore
and yet I'm telling people on the
podcast and sharing writing tips and yet
I wasn't doing it and I was like well
how can we do it social accountability
get online hold yourself accountable to
write at least 10 minutes every day and
create a community around it so that's
it's just we're all experimenting here
people and I think a lot of you all have
listened to enough of these podcasts to
know that even like guys 20 years in are
like I'm still experimenting I'm still
trying to figure it out you know so
you're not a meaning to the struggles I
recently recently released a free ebook
for comedy oh great okay it's um it's
about money 11 years and in that I talk
a little bit about writing and in that I
explain how every year like someone
comes up to me and goes how do you write
and every year it's a different answer
because I'm like oh now I type them out
now I write them this way now I
shortened you know it's like and so I
kind of go
a little bit into that because yeah it's
like I'm 11 years in and I'm still like
I don't I don't have the perfect method
and I don't think I ever will
yeah where it's all trial and error
people so this was incredible thank you
to everyone that posted questions and
curiosity we ended up getting I mean
there's more people watching than I
thought for a Sunday and there's more
questions that we got so if you found
this helpful
share this with other comics let them
know this group exists you know anyone
listening to the podcast if you want to
join the group and start connecting with
other comics and up in your game it's
linked in the show notes as well but
Zach let them know where they can keep
up with you and all that jazz as well
again just go to Zach line and podcast
on Instagram mmm that's that's what I
mostly be but if you need anything else
from me or you want to check out any of
my shirt designs I talked about or any
of that stuff just Zack Lyman comm and
my free ebook is up there sure it's
linked to my podcast all that so yeah
grapes that's me yeah we'll be sure to
link all those in the show notes as well
for people listening to the podcast so
hot breath averse Zack Lyman he's an
ally okay see if you have any questions
reach out to him with any questions
reach out to me with any questions this
Facebook group I really feel like will
answer a lot of your questions there's a
lot of good discussions that go on in
here especially now more than ever we're
getting very interactive and very
granular in terms of topics we're
talking about the day that are timely
and it's a lot of fears and struggles a
lot of us are going through so the more
we can help each other I think the
better we're all going to be for it so
if you haven't already subscribed to the
YouTube page of this podcast I just
posted up great video from Ian bagg is
top 5 crowd work tips as well as the
breakdown of bill burns joke formula
there's a lot of good stuff going on
over at that YouTube page so definitely
subscribe to that share this with other
comics and we'll be back next Monday
how about that everybody know if you
know it say it right here on hard proof
all right Zach Lyman thanks for hanging
out buddy have a good day thank you all
right thank you